ladies and gentlemen I give you the  Pruitt home school class of 2011  congratulations on choosing Phelps  University for your online bachelor's  degree you will not leave the house  unless I say so  is that different from any other day  mom's making me go to college at home  this isn't really the best time right  now what is it you do want to do I want  to go to fashion school talk about a  waste of money  your dog daughter ran off to her dad's  didn't she man she's no longer a minor  officer hilling he'll brainwashers got a  game plan find a job  mom's right the world sucks are you  doing home I want to kill myself that's  exactly the Branch Davidian said  smothering my kid  what's going on it's called an  intervention is this what all the [ __ ]  are wearing these days I don't have any  experience with really great sense of  fashion said okay  Oh toad to our working girl discount  this calls for a celebration  I want to go to a fashion school I'd  like to register for classes  you